-Welcome back to the show.
Thank you so much
for coming on, bud.
-Nice to see you.
Thanks for having me.
-I missed you.
The last couple times we talked
was through Zoom.
-Yeah, which is crazy.
-Yeah, and now we're here.
Thank you for being here
in person.
How are you?
How's the family?
-I'm good.
Everybody's good.
Kids are good.
They're all almost grown.
You know, we're about to have
our own little empty nest.
Yeah.
-You are, really?
-Well, not, yet,
but, like, my youngest is 12.
-You've got some time.
-It's right around the corner.
[ Laughter ]
It goes by fast.
-That's got years.
You got years yet.
-She's already
traveling the world
jumping horses
and doing her thing.
-You sent me a photo here.
Here, look at this.
How gorgeous.
Come on. How cute is that?
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Of course, she picked the most
expensive sport possible, but...
[ Laughter ]
-Did you try to talk
her out of it or anything?
-No, she loves it.
And she takes so much pride
in the little stuff.
She's at the barn every day
shoveling poop.
-Taking care.
-Yeah, she's up before me.
-Look at this shot.
This is great.
Look at this.
-But do you notice,
she's looking
at the photographer?
She's not looking where
she's supposed to be jumping.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, she knows.
She's like "Insta, Insta," yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And how are the boys?
-Boys are good.
I got them playing golf.
-That's amazing.
-And now my wife can't tell me
I can't go play.
[ Laughter ]
I just say
I'm going with the kids.
-Yeah, it's daddy-son time.
It's a boys trip.
-We just went to England and
Ireland and played and hung out.
-That must be amazing.
-No, I didn't give them
any Guinness.
They're 16 and 14.
-I didn't ask that --
-Don't imply
that I gave them beer.
-I didn't ask that question
at all.
[ Laughter ]
-No, 16 and 13, almost 14.
-I'm sure, 16, yeah, yeah.
Are they good at golf?
Are they like their dad?
-They're better than me.
They started young,
so they were smart, you know?
They like --
Well, actually they started --
they were on punishment,
so they could only play golf,
which was good.
And then they actually
started to like it.
So now they're continuing
to play.
-Yeah, I think that's the way
to do it.
Why not? Yeah.
-Put them on lockdown
and give them a club.
[ Laughter ]
-I saw a photo,
you and James Caan together here
at a golf tournament.
He just passed away.
This is you, James Caan,
and Sylvester Stallone
at a charity --
This is at an event.
-I believe
it was at Jimmy's event.
Yeah, he threw an event
every year at El Cab.
-What was he like?
What was James Caan like?
-The best.
-Just great.
-The first time
I worked with him, he goes,
"You know I'm a dream
to work with, right?"
And then I literally called him
"The Dream" ever since.
-Is that right? "You know,
I'm a dream to work with."
-He's amazing.
I got to spend some time
with him not too long ago,
actually.
We went to go and visit
another friend.
I went to his house, hung out,
and then we realized
we had another friend,
who was a dear friend of ours
who was not well.
So we kind of put Jimmy
in the car, we went to see him,
and we got to -- yeah.
-He's a good guy, right?
-Yeah.
It just puts things
into perspective.
I mean, life goes by so short.
So anybody, you know,
people, friends getting older,
reach out to them.
Tell them you love them.
Stay as close and connected
as possible.
-We're gonna miss James Caan.
[ Applause ]
I want to talk about
your new movie, "Me Time."
Because you know, Kevin Hart,
he's a pal of the show,
and I think you guys
would be great together.
Is this the first time
you guys worked together?
-It is.
You know, he came --
We met long ago, and he was
like, "I want to work with you.
I want to work with you."
So I like, "Cool. I can't wait."
And then I'd, like, send him
all these different ideas.
He passed on everything
I sent him.
[ Laughter ]
And then all of a sudden,
he sends me a movie
where I'm supporting him.
And then he's got me
ass naked -- excuse my language.
He's got me in Daisy Dukes
on a boat.
I'm like,
is this supposed to be funny,
or is it just making fun of me?
[ Laughter ]
-I think the first scene, you
were naked in the first scene.
-Yeah.
In the very first scene,
in front of like, you know,
a crew of 200 people,
another hundred extras.
But I had sneakers on.
-That counts.
-I had some Travis Scott's on.
-That counts as something, yeah.
And I heard that you invited him
to work out with you,
and he refused, Kevin.
-Oh, he never showed up.
[ Laughter ]
He's so busy,
he barely showed up to work.
I mean, I was just looking
at our text chain earlier.
And it's like,
"I'm on my way, buddy.
I'll be right there.
Running five behind.
I'm five minutes behind."
Always -- yeah.
-He's doing something.
-Yeah, which is amazing.
I mean, he really, kind of --
We started joking about it,
about all the different things
that we do
outside of our primary business.
-Kevin Hart's
the busiest man on Earth.
-Yeah, but you know what?
what I loved about him
and I love about you,
and I love about Will Ferrell,
is that guys --
just genuinely nice guys
who just genuinely
like to make people laugh.
-Aw, yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And when you get into
the snapping and going
back and forth with Kevin,
he'll start it.
He'll say something
to insult you.
But then he'll say something
after when you come back at him
to make you feel bad.
[ Laughter ]
-He'll say something real nice.
-He's really slick.
-He is a pro.
-He's finessed it.
-Can you tell me what the
movie's about and who you play?
-I play a guy named Huck Dembo,
who's his best friend
who's never quite grown up.
Kev plays the stay-at-home dad
whose wife is finally like,
she's going on a job,
she's taking the kids,
so she's kind of encouraged him
to go and have fun.
-Yeah.
-And I've never grown up.
I'm hanging around with,
basically,
teenagers or kids half my age,
and I screw up his whole life.
Everything that he has
that's safe and comfortable
gets destroyed by my craziness.
-He's just trying
to get a little me time.
-Yes.
-And you destroy his life.
And it's quite fun and funny.
Because John Hamburg,
who's fantastic --
he wrote and directed it --
he's just done this great job
of really kind of
making it entertaining
for both kids and adults.
Like there's lots of great
adult humor in there,
but kids don't quite get it.
And then there's lots of great
stuff for the kids, as well.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Mark Wahlberg
and Kevin Hart in "Me Time."
Take a look at this.
-Wake up!
-Don't flick him!
You have to gently grasp.
Cover his mouth and blow slow,
steady breaths into his nostril.
[ Tires screech ]
-We're here, fools.
-Wait! Wait!
Stop, stop!
I said, "Don't."
-I got it.
-Go on.
Car.
Car, car.
-Slow down!
-Hey!
[ Horn honks ]
-Hey, you got it from here?
-I got it.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Horn honking ]
-Let's go, you idiot!
-Hold on, hold on.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait!
-What?!
[ Door opens, bell chimes ]
-God damn it.
Did you do this?
-No!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Busted.
Busted.
Mark Wahlberg, everybody.
"Me Time" premieres on Netflix
August 26th.
Mark and I are playing a fun
game when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.